c'est un personnage de l'histoire
iranienne qui s'en va le premier
président de la république islamique
d'iran abolhassan bani sadr a reçu un
dernier hommage une inhumation à
versailles autour de sa famille et plus
d'une centaine de personnes de la
communauté iranienne ça permet un peu de
si vous voulez de deux mois en ressentir
la douleur quand elle est partagée bas
surtout avec des gens que j'embrasse
alors que qui pleurent que je ne connais
même pas il a combattu toute sa vie sans
jamais rien lâcher toujours dans le sens
de la démocratie et des droits de
l'homme et pour la grandeur de l'iran
après son exil en france en 1981
abolhassan bani sadr continuer le combat
depuis versailles un domicile placé sous
protection policière hommes politiques
mais aussi grand père il s'occupait de
ses petits-enfants
merci d'avoir est un exemple de force de
combativité
jusqu'au dernier instant pour proche de
l'ayatollah khomeini il a participé à la
révolution iranienne en 1979
élu président de la république islamique
d'iran 1980 il est destitué 17 mois plus
tard et contraint à l'exil en cause ses
positions sur la démocratie et sur les
libertés individuelles j'ai passé toute
ma jeunesse
à suivre son parcours et puis c'est un
homme qui aimait bien il aimait bien les
gens
et donner beaucoup d'importance à
surtout à l'indépendance la liberté v
démocratie cette cérémonie l'occasion de
respecter la dernière volonté d'alassane
bani sadr reposer en france tant que la
démocratie ne sera pas instauré en iran